the question of whether or not the jets
will trade sam darnold previous reports
indicated that that they would make a
decision after they evaluate the
incoming draft class joe douglas the gm
of the team meeting with the media
yesterday on the question of whether he
is willing to entertain trade offers for
sam darnold here he is
i will answer the call um you know if
it's made and so
you know
as it pertains to sam i mean i like i
said sam sam's a we think a dynamic
player in this league um with
unbelievable talent and who's really
really
has a chance to
to really hit his outstanding potential
moving forward but um you know
like like i said earlier um if calls are
made i i will i will answer them
[Music]
that's the next best thing to take in
the for sale sign with a mallet out in
the yard and just banging it into the
ground because it sounds like the jets
who gave up the sixth overall pick and
three second rounders to move up to
number three three years ago to get sam
darnold are ready to get what they can
for him because they know they're
getting a franchise quarterback or a
potential franchise quarterback with the
second pick in the draft it's going to
be zach wilson or it's going to be
trevor lawrence either way fine by us
let's go ahead and and get value while
we can for sam darnold before some of
these other teams out there that are
looking for quarterbacks address their
needs elsewhere yeah no doubt about it i
mean the jets are
you know in my opinion an unbelievable
position they really are uh as you know
and we've discussed a lot i'm a sam
darnold fan i i do think you could still
win football games with him i still
think he has talent like we've talked
about it hasn't been much of a
supporting cast you know i think there's
enough positives that i've seen over the
few years ago hey if they can just help
him out a little bit you can win games
with him now you know my thoughts about
zach wilson yeah i think zach wilson's
special out of byu but that's and and
we'll see i i think there's people in
the nfl that think that as well but
we're going to see what that is but with
them they have so many options it's you
know keep sam darnold okay it's trade
sam darnold and
drafted zach wilson or trevor lawrence
who's ever there and i expect it to be
zach wilson's who's there because i
still think jacksonville is going to
take trevor lawrence i do uh it just
there's too many dots that connect there
that may that make sense to me but also
in the fact that
you know they could come to the
determination and just go wait
we like sam darnold
we'll sit here
and we'll just see what gets thrown at
us is there a team that's going to get
real real thirsty for zach wilson and
throw out a unbelievable trade package
to to get him and now they could be
sitting pretty and maybe they're the
ones that move down a few spots but
collect a few second rounders and things
like that so from that aspect man the
jets have a lot of options and joe
douglas is going to have his work cut
out for him as far as how he wants to
work this out and play this game
one of the reasons to make a move on
darnold is before may three that's when
the fifth year option kicks in and if
they're going to take a quarterback you
don't want the fifth year option that's
now as of this year i finally researched
it refreshed my memory fully guaranteed
the moment that it's exercised not just
guaranteed for injury so i'd say may 3
is the absolute deadline for getting
darnold to another team this year he's
due to make roughly 4.8 million dollars
in total compensation in the last year
of his rookie contract they've paid out
a lot he got a 20 million dollar signing
bonus at the third overall pick in the
draft and hey i said with him then
what i'll say again now
franchise quarterbacks typically the
easiest way to find them in the draft
specifically top of the draft yeah you
have an opportunity to get one that you
think is going to be a franchise
quarterback you do it if it works
awesome if it doesn't
you'll be back there again
soon enough to try again with a new gm
and a new head coach but you'll still be
back again to try again before too long
yeah no you're exactly right and with
the the no you know with the rookie
salary cap and all of that now i mean
it's just not that hard to move on so
this is what you know they're they're
gonna have to weigh this this is why joe
douglas gets paid the big bucks and
robert sala and mike lafleur they're
going to have to evaluate this figure
out what's best for their organization
you know as you heard me say yesterday
you know again i'm a sam darnold fan i
won't be mad at the just keep him and he
does fit
that system the shanahan mike lefleur
matt lefleur style of play there's no
doubt he could play in that system and i
think he can thrive but when i look at
zach wilson i just go
it's more than fit in that system it's
it's he's the perfect guy for that
system like perfect he's aaron rodgers
like we're seeing up in green bay right
now you know so there's that except he's
gonna be younger and and more athletic
and and those type of things right now
so that's where i get excited if i'm a
jets or a jets fan or anything like that
and uh we'll see where they go but but
they got a they got a great spot to be
in at number two and we'll see where it
goes
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports